tomorrow night 24 hours from right now
in this hour President Trump will
deliver a prime-time address to all
Americans surrounding what is now a
crisis at our southern border and that
brings us to our first Hannity watched
tonight as we speak a partial government
shutdown is still in effect as Democrats
bury their heads in the sand close their
eyes and pretend that America's borders
are totally safe and secure they are not
in fact Democrats are adamantly refusing
to give Border Patrol agents the tools
they desperately need and are asking for
and that is a strategic wall on the
southern border but now even one top
Democrat tonight admitting that
President Trump does in fact have the
power to build the wall without any
congressional approval whatsoever take a
look this President Trump had the
ability have the authority to declare a
national emergency have the military
build his wall well unfortunately the
short answer is yes there is a provision
in law that says the president can
declare an emergency it's been done a
number of times but primarily it's been
done to build facilities in Afghanistan
in Iraq and in this case I think the
president would be wide open to a court
challenge saying where's the emergency
all right where's the emergency we will
answer that question pay close attention
to all the following statistics that of
course the hate Trump media hate Trump
Democrats they are not telling you they
are ignoring now in the past two years
alone criminal aliens they have been
responsible for approximately look at
this number 235 thousand violations of
the law including four thousand
homicides thirty thousand sex crimes and
get this over 100,000 violent assaults
in just 20 18 17 thousand individuals
with criminal records they were
apprehended at the border and the crisis
goes much much deeper in towns and
cities all across this country we know
about the opioid crisis 300 Americans
are killed every single week from heroin
90% of that heroin is flooding across
our southern border and that death toll
by the way is equal think about this to
the number of American troops killed
every week in Vietnam during the year
1968 that was
the wars deadliest year and over a
10-year period total Americans killed
from illegal drugs coming across the
southern border will be nearly three
times higher than the total number of US
troops killed in Vietnam there is your
crisis by any definition but don't
expect to see this on any other network
of course Donald Trump wants something
just against it instead of reporting
facts and truth they seem content with
just trashing Trump voters blaming us
for seeing the truth over on fake News
CNN Rick Wilson first trashed Trump
supporters suggesting that we didn't
have teeth now he's saying that we're
just not sophisticated enough we're not
smart enough to understand the issue
involving border security take a look
the idea of a physical wall it Donald
Trump loves selling this to his base and
again these are people who are not
sophisticated they are not bright they
do not understand the complexity okay
here we go again now with here we go
with with condescending to us in the
Trump Trump's target audience he is a
con man who works unsophisticated people
very success you know what and won't
fake news CNN insult our intelligence
conspiracy TV MSNBC they're referring to
Americans we the people as cowards take
a look like it's sort of a lot of
Republicans is they can see that Trump
is driving them off the cliff but they
look at the short term and they fear not
the general election in 2020 but they
fear the potential that Trump and a
trump back candidate to primary them and
beat them before they even got to
November is that fear panic cowardice
stupidity it's all those things but it
is the thing that I think has been the
governing dynamic in Republican politics
for the last year remember last week I
was talking about well we have the hate
Trump Democrats you have the hate Trump
media and I told you about the
information crisis I went into great
detail personal attacks won't ever stop
this show from reporting truth and for
us and most Americans this is not a
political game we're now seeing this is
about life and death this is about
innocent brave law-abiding Americans and
legal immigrants litter
really dying because our borders are not
secure now we know the story of officer
Singh he was gunned down by an illegal
immigrant just after Christmas he was
just put to rest this weekend his five
month old son he will never know his
father that's life and death and the
person responsible for that heinous act
had a criminal track record he should
have been turned over to ice he should
have been deported but in California
well they have sanctuary cities but the
whole state is a sanctuary state and
those policies prevented that from
happening
government policies are now literally
aiding and abetting law breaking and
paving the way for future crimes when
did you think the government would act
and aid and abet criminals and like
every other Democrat you have the
outgoing governor of California Jerry
Brown burying his head in the sand but
really he ought to be taking
responsibility take a look the CSS
county sheriff has come out you know
pretty critical of the sanctuary state
policies that you signed into law in
2017 what do you make of that criticism
and do you think that perhaps a side
effect of those laws is that more bad
actors might fall through the cracks no
I don't think so he was arrested and
brought into jail before the sanctuary
law was even enacted so ice the
immigration people could have gone out
and got it gotten him the police say the
sheriff could have told the Immigration
Service
I think people now are looking to blame
somebody because of the terrible things
that happened but had nothing to do with
the law of California no sanctuary
states literally prevent criminals that
would normally have been handed over to
ice it makes it illegal that means they
go free what happened to officers saying
is all too common an occurrence now have
you heard the name of Pierce Corcoran on
December the 29th he was killed by
suspected illegal immigrant driving
without a license without insurance and
on the wrong side of the highway Pierce
was only 22 years old tonight on this
show his parents will join us right
after our opening monologue also tonight
the American people and the public needs
to start asking some really important
tough questions how many of our fellow
citizens have been murdered because of
secured borders now if that's not a
national emergency I don't know how we
would ever define one and by the way
this emergency is taking place on both
sides of the border here are the facts
60,000 inadmissible or illegal
immigrants are turned away from our
borders every single month a record
number of migrants are overwhelming
American detention facilities causing
them to be dangerously overcrowded and
one out of every three migrant women
those that try to make the trip to our
southern border sadly tragically evil
occurs and they are assaulted sexually
and last month alone 20,000 children was
smuggled or traffic right here into the
United States and thousands more have
died on that arduous difficult hard
journey across the border
president Trump has long warned about
this incredibly serious situation but
well as Nancy Pelosi is reaction to
these devastating facts according to Fox
News during a briefing with our Homeland
Security Secretary Nielsen Pelosi said I
reject your facts to which Nielson
responded quote these aren't my facts
these are the facts during recent porter
negotiations all right so this weekend
the vice president Pence Nancy Pelosi
Chuck Schumer well they didn't bother to
show up for the vice president instead
Nancy and Chuck tea I guess they were
too busy they sent their aides to
negotiate with the vice president of the
United States that's how seriously
they're taking what is now a deadly
issue and then of course arrogantly
offering Oh we'll give you $1 for the
border wall
well if that's her attitude Nancy
Pelosi's is she gonna offer the families
who lost loved ones any financial
compensation they're gonna is that the
Queen aouda fine compassionate
liberalism what does she have to say to
all the angel moms and angel dads and
kids when a what will she say when
officers singh's son is 16 years old or
looking to get into college we showed
you the numbers drugs are pouring across
our borders leading to even more death
and more destruction this is not about
the 98 percent of people that want a
better life because they come from
countries of poverty and want
opportunity and freedom that we all take
for granted we're not worried about them
we're just asking they come legal
it's about the 2% those that are
committing crimes human trafficking drug
trafficking violent offenders but even
the thousands of good honest immigrants
hoping across our border because they do
on a better life or they are trafficking
themselves human trafficking assaults
happen even killed during that dangerous
trek all through Mexico without a doubt
this is a national emergency it's time
to build the wall the president is right
to fight to protect American lives but
how do you negotiate with people they
won't even send sit down they send their
aides to negotiate with the vice
president people who won't even
recognize that the problem exists people
that were jacked truth and simple facts
and care more about political optics
than the lives and the well-being of
Americans and while Democrats to try
their best to ignore very real serious
crisis continue to obsess about one of
their favorite fantasies all they want
to talk about Donald Trump impeachment
Donald Trump and Pietra which as we
explained last week is not going to
happen now in the Senate they won't get
2/3 of Republican senators all they will
do is distract and divide the American
people and they won't be serving their
constituents less than one day after
being sworn in freshmen democratic
congresswoman Rasheeda to lead went on a
vulgar rant vowing to impeach the mf'er
the president over the weekend she
doubled down on our idiotic remarks once
again calling for his impeachment and
said that Trump has quote met his match
the radical far left the new Congress is
off to a great start their new rising
star New York congresswoman Alexandria
Acacio Cortes is continuing to try and
sell Americans on this far left radical
vision for America portraying socialism
as some sort of path to paradise arguing
that we shouldn't let facts get in the
way really take a look when people hear
the word socialism they think Soviet
Union Cuba Venezuela is that what you
have in mind
of course we have in mind and one of my
policies most closely resemble what we
see in the UK in Norway in Finland and
Sweden the Washington Post recently
awarded you four Pinocchios for
misstating some statistics about
Pentagon spending if people want to
really blow up one figure here or one
word there I would argue that they're
missing the forest for the trees I think
that there's a lot of people more
concerned about being precisely
factually and semantically correct than
about being morally right it's only 21
trillion dollar mistake why pay
attention to little facts and figures so
ask yourself why is she so afraid to
explain how to pay for it because the
only way to pay for it is with your
money and she wants to raise taxes she's
already thrown his support behind get
this a 70% tax rate for American
citizens but remember the bottom 50% of
wage earners pay less than 3% of income
taxes already and by the way keep in
mind she'll definitely need a lot more
of your money if she wants to accomplish
the radical agenda so don't be fooled
paying for massive entitlements like
government-run health care government
mandated climate change
government-funded college for all it
will require massive heavy taxes on all
Americans not just the millionaires and
billionaires that are so often demonized
interestingly even the views Whoopi
Goldberg had some pretty choice words
for the freshman congresswoman's big
plans let's take a look I would
encourage you to sit still for a minute
and learn a job
because there are people in that party
who have been working their tails off
they know a lot and they know a lot you
could and you could learn some stuff
before you start pooping on people and
what they've done you got to do
something too
and by the way congresswoman Acacio
cortez you were welcome on this program
if you want to have a real debate we'll
give you the full hour I'll even give
you three bonus hours of my radio show
on 600 of the biggest stations in the
country but don't hold our breath shall
we alright of course she first needs to
denounce her many radical followers for
what a disgusting attacks on the House
Minority Whip Steve Scalise over the
weekend congressman Scalise he was hit
with a wave of extremely disturbing
comments from supporters of Acacio
Cortes during a Twitter exchange on tax
reform now with some sending violent
messages about remember the attempted
assassination of GOP congressmen by a
far left radical James Hodgkinson in
2017 Scalise was shot nearly died
seriously injured comments including
quote kick his cane snipe his ass Wow
and not following that incident
congressman Scalise tweeted quote well
happy to continue this debate on the
floor of the people's house but it's
clearly not productive to engage here
with some of your radical followers
hashtag stay classy congressman Scalise
will join us later in the show
now of course this is all a part of the
Democratic Party's hard turned to the
left a lot of this now is based on
hatred a lot of it is now obsession
fixation every second minute hour of
every day
hey Trump one of the champions of the
far-left Elizabeth Warren she's now
seeing her 2020 presidential hopes
wither right before her eyes during a
visit to Iowa over the weekend the
progressive hopeful from Massachusetts
was again pressed on our now infamous
DNA debacle and she's now come up with a
brand new excuse for her Native American
lies telling the audience quote tribal
citizenship is very different from
ancestry senator 1ee just stop while
you're ahead and admit it you were
caught deceiving voters your employers
and your friends and everybody else
now even our own congressional
colleagues they seem to be taking notice
report from Politico Democratic senators
they are keeping their distance and
withholding any endorsements especially
as former vice president crazy uncle Joe
Biden is reportedly on the verge of
making his final decision on 2020 we'll
have a lot more leader in the show on
all those